you know we should fix her up with
Bernice his son what's his name - doctor
Oh Vince and he's not a doctor is a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
an kid and who should we fix him up with
her
Oh now sell you know I'm still getting
over the tragic loss of my wife she was
such a strong female woman with nice
heavy breasts who's that oh that's my
neighbor hey Larry ah hey Greg Greg ah
that was it
Lester oh I have so much trouble
remembering probably because our
relationship is so casual morning ladies
hi oh I'll do it laughs without me
I need to talk to Larry about an issue
with our shared fence Larry I need to
talk to you about an issue with our
shared fence yes I also need to discuss
this shared fence issue with you okay
they're out of earshot why are you up so
early
no reason just excited to face a new day
oh because ever since we've been down
here you've been a little depressed have
I don't need the burrito
[Music]
okay fine I may have had a teensy bit of
trouble adjusting when we first got here
for like 16 see little months but I took
your advice and I got a job doing what I
sell ATVs now yeah well the truth is
these little babies sell themselves
they're super fun and they're a lot
safer than you might think if you're
standing next to one if you're driving
it it's actually much more dangerous
than you could possibly imagine well a
job is good I know being stuck down here
in Florida isn't ideal but we need to
make the best of it in fact I'm applying
for a promotion at my new job ah very
noisy sand if all goes well tonight you
might be neighbors with Greg Stickney
assistant manager very double noise well
I'm off to work you might want to stand
back kinda in the blast zone here I want
to forget the strap safety first
Greg Larry what's going on any idea why
Oh Marshall HUS called this special
meeting I don't know do you think she
saw the video we've been on the Internet
to lure Jimmy Figgis down here corndog
peened by go-cart its pwned but that was
really adorable well she has it would
ruin our entire plan here she comes
gentlemen so so how's it going it's good
it's really good keep it a little proof
no contact with Brooklyn no one's
questioned our identities definitely
staying off the net right Craig right
that's it
that's all you have to say to me yeah I
think we're good so nobody's gonna ask
me how I'm doing
oh I didn't think this was a personal
conversation it's not turned back when I
watch a movie this is official business
I was just testing you because Greg is
the kind of person who cares about his
friends and can sense when something is
off with him there's something off with
you Marshall house I don't know what I
mean I met someone
okay and um I mean it's not my husband I
mean nothing's happened yet but my
entire body is on fire he's Cuban is
this still official business of course
it is shut up and watch the movie yeah
pop quiz if Larry were married and
everything was fine
and I mean honestly everything is
totally fine sure but he knew that one
night with this person could give him
everything he needed for the rest of his
life why'd he do it yes yes good what if
this person that Larry met was young I
mean really young well I don't think
Larry would do anything illegal you know
it seems to me Larry has needs and
deserves to have those needs met
Gregg you're really great at being
undercover no you both pass the test
let go let me not hey everyone
sorry I'm late so what's this secret
meeting all about you guys know I'm not
medically cleared for another week it's
not a secret meeting Jake it's an
intervention the tips have to go what
why Jake we're worried about you and you
look very stupid come on guys I think
they're kind of cool retro no they're
terrible Amy come on you're digging the
tips right no I feel like I'm kissing
Vanilla Ice there was a time you would
have jumped at that chance they have to
go all right you guys got me I did it as
a joke I kept them ironically pretty
funny right I went too deep down there
in Florida at one point I think I forgot
where the tip of me ended and the base
of the tips began before we just chopped
them off would anybody like to say some
final words no that was one word that
counts Thank You Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it me and Jake are chip buds
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you know what I do see it it's mad
what's that
attention squad pretty dainty way to
make an announcement it's a workplace I
wanted to be respectful well as someone
at a high risk for a spook related death
thank you as I was saying it's time for
round four of the Halloween Jake Peralta
here to tell you that tonight is the
night for the Halloween price Amy
already went over this
what games what are you doing I always
announce the heist yeah Amy what the
hell are you doing exercising my right
to announce the heist as the defending
champion defending champion the only
reason you won is cuz no one knew you
were even playing it was a pathetic act
of pure cowardice oh she's your
girlfriend well not tonight she isn't
although don't kiss anyone else I love
you so much
now then this one's for all attention
squad tonight don't y'all three really
should have coordinated what I really
should be the one to introduce the heist
as the last legitimate champion perrault
hasn't won since the first year ISA has
been yeah well this has been has been
with yo mama all week sorry I feel like
I crossed a line I apologize everyone
enough we know the heist is happening no
my ex-wife just died No thank you for
joining me for what promises to be the
diggity dopest tree-lighting in the
history of the nine-nine I don't
understand where's the tree it was
inside us all along brilliant Jake no
Charles not everything was inside of us
all along the tree is right here
cool can we go now obviously not behold
the greatest inflatable tree that murica
has to offer and now in the immortal
words of Saint Nick turn on the
compressor here that the sound of
Christmas it's deafening it's getting
really big once I've treated you get
it's a jumbo it says it's ten meters
tall
that's roughly thirty two point eight
one eight someone unplug it I plug it
now we can't it's one of his own Club
okay the tree has been contained wait we
left a man behind well
Terry's trapped in the break room
forever only thing we can do now is move
on with our lives is what Terry would
have wanted god bless us everyone good
morning everyone
oh my goodness Sarge
what are the chances I say zero ah I
mean when Genevieve gotten these
suspenders I thought I'd lean into it go
for the whole look but I didn't want to
step on your toes that being said you
know what this means
don't do this Charles oh it's already
done gather round y'all it's time to
play who wore best I'd really rather not
because you're a little chicken who wore
it best who wore it best who wore it
best Terry what come on you should
change Boyle not here
oh hello yes guys guys check it out it's
caca fell asleep in the break room so I
put his hand in a bowl of warm water
come on man that's the stupidest prank
ever
ah no it's the smartest because it
involves biology I bet it worked already
let's go Jack
Hitchcock no he's drowning
he's drowning save a man take it back
Jake great friend in the world
great form captain your calves are
looking Toya Peralta what are you doing
if razzmatazz we needed to stop
somewhere outside the precinct yes
you'll hear too great sir we've
discovered a lieutenant Hawkins is dirty
squad is an investigator with golden
gang bank robbers they are the robbers
sorry Brenda Hipparchus is robbing banks
why she invites you onto a task force
we're working on a case that could have
exposed her this way she can keep tabs
almost turn it get down why is this so
hard for me do I even have quads and
normally I'd say we'd report this to
internal affairs
but Hawkins is one of the most revered
detectives in the NYPD is you gonna go
after her you better have the proof to
back it up well then I guess that only
leaves us one option and now wag those
tails
find out everything we can about the
squad and take her down from the inside
keep wagging
I am wagging Brenda
[Music]